I knew I wanted to come to Carnegie
Mellon for research at such great
institution but in general and then
soccer was just kind of like the cherry
on top
I think it's like a new kind of teamwork
that you learn working in this kind of
lab I think it's been really beneficial
to just have a different experience of
teaching and learning and hands-on
learning that you are able to
participate in such an advanced level
project while you're still in your
undergraduate all of us are very driven
people in players if we chose this
school for its academics and I think
that really shows up in our practices I
would definitely recommend playing
collegiate sport it actually it gives
you so many opportunities like I never
would have wound up in this lab had I've
not been teammates with Sam the basics
that I learned in Mendon lab translated
so well to why I wanted to do outside of
school dr. Menon is such a good person
like he sees the best in everyone I
really believe that and it was just
really lucky that I got to find
something that worked out that way I
think craniamon is really unique in the
way that it's really a melting pot of
cultures in general you have people from
all over the world plus all different
perspectives and ideas that same
academic drive is the same passion and
heart that we put to our team and our
playing my experience coming here it's
been one of the greatest experiences of
my life to be part of a team like our
team has the goal of winning the NC
double-a tournament and we're number
seven so we're doing something right
right
you